هي وقفه شكر ووفاء لهذا الانسان هذا الخبر
الحزين اللي هز عالم الفن عن عمر ناهز
الثانيه والخمسين عاما توفي الفنان
السعودي فهد الحيان بعد اصابته بازمه
قلبيه مفاجاه الحيان كان رمزا من رموز
الكوميديا السعوديه عرفه الجمهور بشخصيه
هازار في الجزء الثاني من المسلسل
الكوميدي طاش ما طاش استمر افاد الحيان في
تقديم هازار حتى الجزء الخامس عشر في
المسلسل وكان فاكهه المسلسل بخفه الظله
وعفويته
عاش الى اولى تجاربه الانتاجيه واحد ابرز
اعمالها شمشا الذي ادى بطولته في عام 2000
او منذ عام 2006 وحقق نجاحا كبيرا على
مدار سته
اجزاء تراجع ظهور الحياه في السنوات
الاخيره على الشاشه لكنه ظل على تواصل مع
جمهوره ومحبيه عبر السوشيال ميديا
[موسيقى]
رحل هزار وانتهى مشوار فني بدا في العام
للفنان السعودي فهد الحيان الذي وافته
المنيه اثر سكته كلبيه مسائل اثنين
كان مسلسل طاش ما طاش بدايه انطلاقته
لمشواره الفني وعرفه الجمهور من خلال عدد
من الشخصيات الكوميديه اشهرها ازار التي
احبها الصغير والكبير يبدا بعدها بحصد
النجوميه ويشارك في عدد من الاعمال وعلى
سبيل المثال للحصر خلك معي ابو العصافير
وهشتقه ومسلسل من ناوي فينا
[موسيقى]
وفي العام 2006 انتج مسلسل غشمشم الذي حظي
فيه بدور البطوله وامتد لسته مواسم ابوي
[موسيقى]
يلا ابوي
ولا تركيش
مسيره فنيه حافله وسخت في ذاكره الجماهيره
بشخصيات متعدده اشهرها هازار ورويشد
وغشمشم ارتفعت بعد وفاته الدعوات وتزاحم
التعازي الوسط الفني في الوطن العربي كافه
لتعزيه ذوي الفنان فهد الحيان الذي ترك
ارثا فنيا خالدا في الاذهان لصباح العربيه
محمد خالد الرياض
رحمه الله عليه وتعازينا الحاره طبعا
لذويه وكل محبيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات